voici la pièce suspecte sur cette photo
en bas de l'écran une lamelle métallique
de 43 cm recouverte en partie d'un
mastic d'avions précise le rapport
une pièce retrouver sur la piste
empruntée par le concorde premières
zones d'ombré
la nature et l'origine exacte de cette
lamelle provient-elle d'un autre avion
le bea ne s'avance pas il confirme
simplement qu'elle est étrangère au
concorde
c'est à partir de cet élément que le
scénario s'ébauche retour sur les faits
à 16h42 le concorde s'aligne sur la
piste 26 air de roissy 32 secondes plus
tard la vitesse de décision est atteinte
impossible pour le pilote d' empêcher le
décollage
dans ce laps de temps ce produit un
terrible enchaînement d'incidents
d'abord un pneu qui éclate dû à cette
lamelle
c'est ce que confirme ce soir le béa des
débris de pneu du concorde ont
d'ailleurs été retrouvés sur la piste
notamment un gros morceau de caoutchouc
pesant plus de 4 kg comme le montre
cette photo en haut de l'écran un
éclatement de pneu qui aurait provoqué
directement ou indirectement précise le
béa
des dégâts sur l'appareil mais lesquels
les débris sont ils allés heurter les
réservoirs ont ils été ingérée par les
réacteurs à cela pas de réponse ni
analyse ni conclusions le bea ne fait
pas non plus la liste des modifications
à apporter sur les concorde
ce sera la mission du groupe de travail
franco britannique sur l'avenir du
supersonique
un groupe dont la prochaine réunion
cruciale est fixée le 7 septembre à
paris
bon